[Music]
Matt Damon recalls vacationing in
Australia with his family and Chris
Hemsworth when things took a scary turn
my daughter my six-year-old got stung by
a jellyfish worse than anything it was
the worst thing oh man I mean even Chris
said he was like mate that's the worst
thing I've ever seen
like it was really bad the 47 year old
actor opened up on Thursdays Ellen about
how it all went down
this thing like literally wrapped around
her it was like this little blue bottle
but these long tentacles that I mean I
could show you pictures that would turn
your head I mean she had like these
looked like shoelaces kind of red
shoelaces around so you saw it was on
her still you had to get it off of her
oh yeah we pulled it off yeah did you
get stung pulling it off yeah a little
bit but not like her after dishing on
his daddy rescue Matt got candid about
his suburbicon director and fellow
father George Clooney yeah I mean the
twins thing I can't even people would
say do you give him advice I don't want
to know I mean I I you know two babies
at once that's yeah
et just spoke with George about the
twins latest milestone three days ago
my children started on what we would
call solid food and it went in fine
I don't know how it goes in as a carrot
and it comes out the way it comes out
but it was shocking it was it was
shocking what's changed
[Music]
you